[Musique]
pas d'amis bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour monsieur vous avez l'air de vous
porter fort bien ouais rien ne peut
m'enlever ma bonne humeur aujourd'hui je
suis belle et très heureux bonjour julie
banque a émis 1
sinon quelle forme tu es superbe ce
matin oui c'est parce que je suis
heureux c'est souvent comme ça plus on
est heureux
plus on met peu et peut-on savoir la
résine cette grande joie font rien de
spécial c'est simplement parce top je
trouve que l'on est très bien tous
ensemble sur cette île sans personne
pour nous embêter
padam padam pas tondre par un pas quasi
mirkazemi enfant tu vas être encore plus
content voilà emile campagne décidément
tous mes amis arrivent les uns après les
autres
c'est formidable rien ne peut mordre en
tout cas ça fait plaisir de voir aussi
heureux viva ben justement
j'apporte une autre bonne nouvelle ouah
je brille encore une bonne nouvelle dit
nous a très vite fekter écoute vous
saviez tout ce que monsieur du snob est
en voyage aux humains et nous nous
sommes tellement bien entre nous ben
justement ma bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
rentre aujourd'hui au cac et leur écoute
les bonnes surprises d'après les
horreurs des bateaux il devrait être là
d'une minute à l'autre qu'elle chauffe
un nouvel avis
casimir qu'est ce qui t'arrive c'est
certainement l'émotion trop de bonnes
nouvelles
facteur pouvez vous répéter ce que vous
venez de dire or pour sûr je dis que
monsieur lucy nobbe rentrée de voyage
aujourd'hui et il sera là d'une minute à
noah
alors cette fois que je suis de bonne
humeur
vous faites tout pour me mettre en
colère mais enfin casimir nous sommes
tous très contents parce que monsieur du
snob est de retour c'est normande par
mois mais il est très gentil
il m'énerve tout le temps il t'aime
beaucoup bon il me met en colère
casimir du exagère reconnaît que très
souvent c'est toi qui lui lance des
piques pourront voilà justement monsieur
mes chers amis vous avez une bonne ligne
vous avez dû voir des gens comme moi
j'ai près des voyages beaucoup plus bon
ah oui qu'à tenir ça nan moi j'ai vu de
très bonne humeur - eh ben moi j'ai vu
les sept merveilles du monde
deux murs que du mur il sait très bien
qu'il ne reste qu'une seule des sept
merveilles du monde
les grandes pyramides toutes les autres
ont été démolies il y à plus de 2000 ans
ne parlons plus des mille ans que j'ai
pu voir voulez vous ça n'a pas
d'importance vous avez rencontré des
gens très intéressants passionnons ma
chère amie passionnant il faut que je
vous raconte tout ça voilà c'est bien le
moment de parler des gens qu'on a
rencontrés au moment où l'on retrouve
ses amis
c'est gentil casinière cette voie du
exagère non-lieu alors chaque fois comme
ceux du snop et là vous vous mettez tous
avec lui contre moi casimir tu n'es pas
juste enfin monsieur du snow fit tout
pour arranger les choses
ça fait rien ça n'a pas d'importance ne
parlons plus des gens que j'ai pu
rencontrer me raconter d'où quelques
secondes
mais que vous dire mon cher ami que vous
dire oui j'ai gagné une course e course
c'est trop drôle oui mais je suis le
champion du monde de la course en sac ce
extraordinaire ça vaut toutes les
félicitations
le champion c'est moi
oui mais moi je serais champion du monde
et j'ai même une coupe à et bien moi je
vous lance un défi
s'il ya lieu c'est très bien vous êtes
près très près ces parties casino
[Applaudissements]
on m'a donné un sac trop petit ce n'est
pas juste
je suis désolé casimir mais j'ai suivi
les mesures que tu m'avais indiqué que
28 fermeture je voudrais mettre un sac
spécial que j'ai préparé lorraine
interdit pas et je ne m'y oppose pas non
plus moi alors j'y vais voilà mon sac
spécial ça y est je crois la voile à
aller pour la deuxième manche préparez
vous messieurs allez 4
hors cac c'est minimiser le tout à fait
remarquer la partie 6 me dont casimir et
excusons comment se fait-il que tu aies
gagné la course en sac sans sauter par à
g passante et n'ont absolument pas
besoin de gentils et me montrer tes
pieds ouvreur mais c'est un sac percée
où tu encore tricher et casimir monsieur
déclaré vainqueur mais je viens de vous
dire que j'avais apporté un lot de
consolation pour le perdant la coupe de
champion du monde de course en sac
c'est pour moi merci monsieur du snob
[Musique]